Doctor, I want to talk about salt. Um, a
lot of people have high blood pressure.
You stay away from salt.
But, we need it.
Well, salt is an essential nutrient.
Sodium and chloride.
You cannot have nerve impulses without
sodium chloride. They're an integral
part of the biochemical system of nerve
transmission.
You cannot move water around in your
body or retain it in the right
compartments inside your blood vessels,
inside your tissues, inside the cells.
You can't keep things in the right
compartment without sodium chloride.
The chief cells in your stomach cannot
make stomach acid
without salt.
Okay?
Salt is the raw material. Sodium
chloride is the raw material to make
hydrochloric acid in your stomach.
Now, two things have happened because of
this terrible criminal advice that
doctors have given. It's criminal.
Anybody else do this to the American
people, they'd be put in jail for a
life. Some of them would be executed
because of the number of people who are
killed over this. Right?
Salt is required to make stomach acid.
You don't have enough stomach acid, you
get reflux, incorrectly called acid
reflux. It's reflux. Reflux is caused by
insufficient amounts of stomach acid.
Not too much stomach acid. So, doctors
even named it the wrong thing, right?
And basically
um, you get reflux when you don't have
enough stomach acid to keep your stomach
environment sterile.
So, yeast begin to grow in there. So,
you eat carbohydrates and sugar, they
ferment that, produce gas. Uh-oh,
heartburn pressure, reflux.
Cuz you have all these things growing in
your stomach.
Okay? When you get a pH too high, you
get a pH above four, all these things
begin to grow. You have a pH under one,
your pepsin works to digest proteins,
and you can absorb minerals, you can
absorb B12. Your pH gets above two, two
and a half, you can't do that.
Okay, so you're in trouble. I mean, you
can take tons of iron supplementation,
and if you don't have any stomach acid,
you can't absorb iron.
Now, here comes the most terrible thing
that's happened to America because of
this inappropriate advice.
Well, there's two things. One, you go
back to 1995,
750 people died during a triple digit
heat wave in Chicago. It was a two-week
heat wave, 1995, I believe it was.
750 people died here in Chicago, and
thousands of people fell out with
heatstroke.
The first thing they give them
intravenously on the way to the hospital
when they had heatstroke is saline
solution, which is
Salt water.
Salt water, yeah.
And it's absolutely criminal that these
750 people who died
were all ones who were on a
salt-restricted diet. They're all
seniors who were on a salt-restricted
diet. They died of heatstroke because of
these doctors didn't have the courtesy
to call these people up
and good manners, just to call them and
say, "Look,
whether you believe in the
salt-restricted diet or not, right now
you need to put a couple of tablespoons
of salt in the gallon of water. Be
sipping on that until the heatwave goes
away." But, they didn't do that. And so,
all those people
who died of heatstroke were under the
care of doctors who were on a restricted
salt diet, those doctors should be put
in jail.
Okay? For almost like the same thing as
vehicular homicide, the same type of
thing as
manslaughter, right? The type of thing.
Um
then, here comes the big one.
Right now,
on the average from This is a Mayo
Clinic study came out in 2009.
They said that as many as
30% 30 people out of 100 American now
have celiac disease and have trouble
absorbing nutrients. And as a result,
there's people with 25 legitimately
diagnosed diseases, which are all
nutritional deficiency diseases. They're
going to 18 different specialists for
all of this.
And and
they're paying, you know, tens of
thousands of dollars a day to deal with
this, and simply a gluten intolerance,
and they can't their intestines are
damaged, they can't absorb nutrients.
Well, when you can't digest
wheat, barley, rye, and oat glutens,
and you absorb these big chunks of
what's called polypeptides, your body
recognizes and
sets up an intolerance to those
partially digested proteins.
You get gluten intolerance, you get
celiac disease or wild syndrome,
inflammatory bowel disease,
diverticulitis, ulcerative colitis,
Crohn's disease. The doctors' approach
to these diseases are cut your
intestines out. I can't understand how
they, you know, you have a malabsorption
problem, they want to cut your
intestines out. That's really dumb.
But, anyway, because they have you on a
salt-restricted diet, you cannot make
stomach acid,
so your pepsin won't work,
and you cannot digest proteins,
including the protein of wheat, barley,
rye, and oats. Now, again,
there's a big research project come out
in 2009 that said, "Uh-oh,
it used to be people got celiac disease
when they were kids.
And if you recognize it, you can save
them from all these terrible diseases,
cuz you can get them off of gluten and
they'd be fine.
Well, now people who could eat gluten
with impunity, they were really big on
eating wheat, barley, rye, and oats, no
problems, but suddenly now at age 50 or
60, they become gluten intolerant.
Well, that's because over the years on a
salt-restricted diet,
they couldn't digest
wheat, barley, rye, and oat glutens down
to their simplest amino acids. Big
chunks called polypeptides are being
absorbed. They set up an intolerance to
it, and now at age 50, 60,
we have 80 out of 100 people
Mhm.
with gluten intolerance because of this
criminal advice to restrict salt.
Mhm.